[Music]
feel wonderful i feel so much better
than i did yes clap
you two or three people who work for me
keep clapping i'll fire all of you happy
thursday spit on myself wow today is a
big day for cnn no no no the age of
consent didn't just get lowered
[Laughter]
just let that s soothed into your brain
it's the one year anniversary of january
6th or as they see it pearl harbor meets
9 11 with a watergate shooter yeah it's
worse than the worst thing ever and of
course you know they're the heroes so
why commemorate it if it's so bad
well first it's easy it's just one day
right i mean try commemorating the riots
after george floyd or jacob blake or the
burning down of various cities and don't
forget the violent melees after trump
won in 2016. you'd have to hold a
commemoration every single day it'd be
like combining groundhog day with rodney
king
but don't hold your breath well unless
you're in an elevator with eric swalwell
we'll get to him later so instead of
acknowledging the many of the dead
caused by those relentless media
approved riots of 2019 and onward the
press chooses to amp up one day of
rioting one they falsely call an
insurrection since no one's been charged
with insurrecting anything hell more
people died at that travis scott show
and worse they salute online narcs who
helped get people arrested for wandering
around that day even after some capitol
police held the doors open for them
yeah our government deputized a nation
of stasi karen's under the lying guise
of sedition to ruin people's lives and
if you don't play the media's game they
will say you're playing the event down
screw them they're lying it's the only
thing they're good at
as we've said before about january 6
it's a riot and riots are bad that's
what makes us good people here at fox we
view all violence as unseemly well
unless it involves a safe word
that reminds me bill hammer i need my
leather mask back
but the legacy media is just faking
outrage to hide their own pro-violence
stance which is like stelter trying to
hide behind a flagpole
see to them crime and death are just
political weapons the kind that can be
hidden when necessary to win an election
and then one to play up in order to not
lose an election let's not forget how
the media manipulated the riots in the
crime wave for political favor
this is a mostly protest uh it is not uh
it is not generally speaking unruly but
fires have been started they're gonna
take your country away and they're
taking down the statues and crime is
rising
oh my gosh it's so bad you listen to
conservative media you would think that
you know
entire cities are just you know enrolled
in fights and fires and whatever we went
out had a great dinner in new york city
tonight people actually walked up to us
and said thank you for i watch you every
night ah that is so not true
no one watches you every night
still like a twinkie that clip never
gets old
but here's the media now january 6
represents an ongoing threat to our
democracy what we saw a year ago today
is something they see as a continuing
clear and present danger to this country
vice president harris invoking the
phrasing of the date that will live in
infamy pearl harbor
9 11 and now january 6. ah kamala's
stupidity will live in infamy and of
course there's joe biden who as
left-wing run cities burned and people
died chained himself to a basement
radiator like he was a lincoln project
intern
wasn't until consultants told him that
all this leftist violence could help
trump win that he spoke up barely and
yet here he is again faking concern
because it takes the heat off his
disastrous presidency and puts it on
trump
we must decide
what kind of nation are we going to be
are we going to be a nation that accepts
political violence as a norm
are we going to be a nation
will we allow partisan election
officials to overturn
the legally expressed will of the people
are we going to be a nation that lives
not by the light of the truth
but in the shadow
of lies for the first time in our
history
a president
had not just lost an election
he tried to prevent the peaceful
transfer of power
as a violent mob breached the capitol
former president who lies about this
election
and the mob that attacked this capital
could not be further away
from the core
american values
doesn't sound like he wants to move on
the problem is the american people see
through this like a peephole in a cnn
bathroom stall
we aren't fooled by the media's orgy of
sanctimony they only cared about january
6 to falsely smear millions of people
who didn't vote for joe while helping
their own dying networks fact is they
need trump like our president needs
metamucil and more trump content helps
boost ratings that are limper than kevin
spacey thumbing through a victorious
secret catalog
see it head is going all in and you
can't blame them consider the mess
they're in a network that spent more
time last year covering their ass than
the news and zero time covering up
jeffrey toobin's weiner
you got multiple anchors accused of
sexual harassment
their only star anchor fired in disgrace
producers either arrested or implicated
in deviant sex crimes that would make
jeffrey epstein want to fly commercial
yeah no wonder they couldn't cover that
story either it hit too close to home i
guess so gas bags like stelter gorge on
january 6th like it was an eclair found
in a trash can rather than the
perversion exploding around him anything
to distract
and they've been wrong so many times on
so many things that they need january
6th more than alec baldwin needs it an
nra instructor
it's really about shelf space the libs
got nothing to sell biden's horrendous
performance is creating a kink in the
supply chain for other news stories
all they have left is doom and gloom
inflation crime covid the border that's
all they have to fill their shelves is
it any wonder that all of this is every
bit as coordinated as their efforts to
beat trump which time magazine boasted
about or openly punishing anyone who
dare bring up hunter biden's laptop and
what coordination it is you got the new
republic usa today the ap the daily
beast the la times the hollywood
reporter and what do they have in common
other than being covered in parrot by
the end of the day
their media interviewing other media
forming a media human centipede feeding
on its own waste high on its own fumes
what's that tell you that nothing ever
happens in life until it happens to the
media crime didn't exist you see until
one day in january put the media in
their idols on center stage what's next
is the cast of hamilton gonna pop by to
commemorate the day
we're privileged to have a contribution
from one of the great creative talents
of our time
lin-manuel
miranda a new year brings hope for the
future
new energy to face the tasks ahead of us
and a renewed promise to strengthen the
foundations of our democracy
[Music]
i was just joking but yeah it turns out
they did get the cast of hamilton this
is so
wow so suddenly according to the media
the world's in danger because they were
in danger when in fact the only person
who was murdered was an unarmed woman
who our brave media dare not mention
ever yeah they finally found a dead
unarmed female protester they didn't
give about meanwhile their lives weren't
as about as much danger as the day when
brian williams was in his third tour on
vietnam
but before that when neighborhoods were
destroyed businesses plundered innocent
people terrorized to the media that was
as alien as an episode of star trek
because they the media wasn't the center
of that universe january 6 though is
their story as opposed to the riots
crime waves you're suffering so for
nearly two years they pretended
everything was great but then january 6
happens and suddenly there's a threat to
our fragile democracy yeah suddenly
they're pro cop after a decade of
painting targets on their backs so they
use this day now to deflect from the
devastation they wrought upon this
country it's the one product they can
fill their shelves with and they hope
you care but you see through it like a
three dollar shower curtain you know
your pain was never the media's concern
your pain didn't validate their core
beliefs in fact your pain exposed how
their own leftism led to our civil
decline to them authentic violence had
to be buried unless they could use it
against you
you'd be a sucker to fall for this and
it's on every republican who does
you hear that liz
welcome tonight's guest
she's more southern than a gun that
shoots cornbread fox business anchor
jagen mcdowell
when this lawyer approaches the bench
it's to knock out a set of 15 presses
act uh former acting attorney general
matt whitaker
he's done more head shots than a
yearbook photographer
the most reliable seal since tupperware
former navy seal rob o'neal
she's like last week's christmas tree
out in the street after covering your
floor with needles
that might be the best one ever that
might be the best one ever i know it's
unfair and wrong but it's still the best
one ever [ __ ] this contributor cat tim
i swear i wasn't going to do any more
drug references for you captain now
they're just hiding them now i'm doing
intro them intravenous that was just
whoever wrote that it made such a good
intro i had to use it
meanwhile all of robs are about killing
people
so rob i haven't seen you in a while how
do you
how do you take this idea that we have
to accept that this is going to be like
a year anniversary like everyone it's
it's ridiculous i mean
the way they're acting about it now that
january 6 and in order to honor it we
should just plow down the washington
monument and put up a statue of
lawmakers hiding behind desks that's
what happened there i mean they're
they're so eager including the cheney
family to send people like me men and
women to war and it's fine with 13
people die in one explosion it didn't
need to happen it's until it comes to
your house right now it's an
insurrection when the only person that
was killed was murdered by one of your
cops if if if as a as a ranged safety
officer raised officer in charge i was
the navy seal for 16 years watching that
clown carry that gun
instagram warriors will yell at me for
that crap yeah yeah and he blasted it
was an it was a negligent just negligent
discharge he shot it into a crowd hit a
woman in the neck a 14-year
air force combat veteran ashley babbitt
not a peep exactly the only two the only
two words that uh president biden say
that only two names he didn't say today
were donald trump or ashley babbitt the
former president didn't mention a woman
that got murdered by an uh
a cop that shouldn't have been there for
28 years yeah oh rob i'm so i you just
get me so pissed just what you it just
gets into my
gut when i think about how that woman
and how her family it just it just rips
me up and then you hear the story the
nonsense about yeah boy they were climb
on the wall we had nowhere to go you're
armed
look i wasn't there
they you don't storm the capitol that
mob mentality hits everyone believe me
i've been there and the only time i've
ever been arrested i deserved it but
what i'm saying is i think i don't i
love cops it wasn't my fault well it was
my fault but
i mean you can tell by the way this
dude's bouncing
not only should he be fired his
instructor should be fired the first guy
that taught him should be fired it's
just it's a shame and they're
politicizing this because this is all
they got exactly degan is there i mean
it is it's kind of a naked desperate
ploy because they see how bad their
their this is going politically the
american public does not care about
an anniversary commemoration there are
going to be they're not going to be
buying any of the coins no i talked to a
lot of folks and um january 6 not coming
up in conversation the media
love a riot a little too much because
see last year they were it was a lot of
work and energy to contain their glee
right because in one moment it seemed to
justify all of the lies all the orange
man bad
that they had peddled for more than four
years and now they just want to relive
that brief moment of glory that moment
in the sun where their ratings were
not
yes that it's so it's like they finally
got off the bench once in high school
and like ran a few yards and got to
second base with a woman that you didn't
have to put a bag over her head
that is that is the media that was a
hell of a mixed metaphor what yeah but
yeah you're right i think you're right
i'm trying to follow it but i believe
you hit on an essential truth you know
uh matt let's talk about this
like
another network we won't mention because
i already made fun of them yep they've
been counting how many times we say
insurrection do we have to say
insurrection if no one's being charged
well and it's not legally an
insurrection if a if nobody's been
charged and b if there was no means or
manner to ever overturn the government i
mean we have we've had 700 people
charged yes all of them broke the law
and should be prosecuted political
violence never appropriate however this
re this riot or whatever you want to
call it mob was never going to take
control of the federal government and
all the apparatus therein you know the
one thing about january 6 we also need
to remember as we're doing this on a
yearly basis is this is when president
trump was kicked off of the major social
media platforms and that was really uh
as anti-american a move as any mob at
the capitol because what it did is it
demonstrated that social media companies
now control speech
and while there are yeah free speech
does not apply to private companies
we need to relook at sort of the power
they have to regulate speech because
it's it's extraordinary oh and also
whenever you whenever you silence
somebody it's not like you actually
silence them you just push them
underground and then they find other
ways and it and then you don't know
exactly what they're saying cat you
understand that don't you
yes you are an insurrectionist
uh the thing
that's that's nice or if you accuse me
of doing intravenous drugs now you
accuse me of being an insurrectionist
and i haven't even got a chance to talk
i know i know last word to you because
you're the most important oh wow okay
wow that was weird um
so
i think that when biden says you know do
we really want to live in a country
where this is normal yeah like i don't
think we need all this and you know the
weird zoom hamilton thing which didn't
really fit in with the rest of the event
that was great
um to not think it's normal because even
on that day i don't think anybody
anybody at all thought it was normal
right exactly nobody turned on the tv
and saw that and was like
changed the channel boring yeah just
another day
so i think that yeah when you make
pronouncements like that obviously
january 6th was bad it was crazy but
nobody thinks this was normal no like we
don't nobody nobody thinks it was normal
even the people that were there that
wasn't a normal day for them but this is
what okay so this is going back to what
rob was talking about about the cheneys
and and and the kinsingers they're
pretending that we thought it was normal
and so
and that that elevates them to act like
they're the they're the they're the
they're the heroic people pointing this
out we're gonna be on the committee no
everybody thought it sucked but we don't
need you guys to be the pawns for the
democrats and there's there's so much
going on inside too there's so so much
behind the scenes of how this actually
got going if you see a grown man wearing
those kind of shorts and an
eight-year-old boy's haircut he's a fed
yes he's doing something he's not yeah
yeah he's there's a lot of questions
it's like the pipe we talk about we
still don't even know what the pipe
would happen with the pipe bomb and also
remember the blm activist that was there
next to um ashley babbitt and he was on
cnn and they paid him do you remember
that at the it was like
anyway oh but the democrats are going to
get to the bottom of it on their
committee yeah yeah all right hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else